oh man isn't it the best life ever
I am having the time am i that right now
but if only there was a game where I
could play and it's been a big time
ah oh my god it it's been a simulator oh
there's a premium edition in the pre
munition you get a golden fidget spinner
and a golden vase I am so [ __ ]
excited I've never been this excited for
a game in my entire life okay here we go
you know what I don't need it anymore
well this Kippur
[Music]
i'vei've been action I've got my bed by
matching back on my feet per minute ah
sick dog what a time to be alive
wait let me try it on after that just
feels right
get yours too and you can all do
together
I am dying I am dying everyone I'm back
on my feet can I hold shift to
accelerate oh yes my chakras perfectly
balanced right now I would hit by
everything and even cancel out this is
incredible what a time to be alive
what a seventeen everyone is so much
like an inevitable pivotal for and over
nuclear war doesn't even matter anymore
because I am playing
fidgets spinner simulator gold in
addition Thank You where's my [ __ ]
point in them one though to be fair can
I even rip a fat vapor can I even wreck
one I don't think I can they didn't
animate it [ __ ] it doesn't matter I've
never been this happy
what is this
here's my business okay the soulmates
been fresh my god I never thought I was
possible to be this happy let's crash
into the ocean we can there's an
invincible vault
okay great oh wow this game is a game
it's a it's a game sky racetrack let's
go hell yeah
I'm like [ __ ] Sonic up in this [ __ ]
that's right
whoa going so fast this is what the new
Sonic game should have been this is way
more entertaining than any other game I
am ever playing I am and I neurotically
enjoying this it's definitely fun I am
having so much fun shut up you don't
know my level of fun it's going so fast
I think I might actually take a shortcut
well you can't jump all the sudden yes I
did it perfect landing
every time whoa what the [ __ ] is this
Oh God other fitted better yes ma'am
follow me yeah Bravo this is dope
awesome this is hella cool yeah Wow okay
if you ever want to be gang [ __ ] my
man with but aback by a frigate spinner
gang then play this game seriously
okay multiplayer what about multiplayer
oh wow I am controlling what seems to be
two characters at the same time the beat
and the chorus and fifty this game is
art this game truly a started a it's a
it's a spitting image of self-reflection
alright this is now a three free game
that's right next one we're going to
play the horror game looks pretty cool
press f to turn on the flashlight
alright locked door okay oh I get it
it's one of these doors simulators oh
really like the sound of that one oh
nice
alright what is that if you are here
then you in-game
you ain't game everybody welcome welcome
if in case you didn't know you in game a
pizza no ah is that the end goal of this
game to find a pizza don't worry pizza I
will find you and I will eat you closed
lies you're not closed my [ __ ] this
[ __ ] pizza I swear to god this is
barricaded maybe I need like an AK sir
all right maybe like a really sharp
pizza you know what I mean
I gotta find all the pizza slices run
but you can't run in this game well you
can don't turn back does that sound
open but I can't or that sound okay I'm
getting along spooked out now got a key
I think oh [ __ ] I think I found the
pizza guys I found the page set really I
beat the game great I was cool haha what
the [ __ ] hey ah yes
okay let's play this game I I'm actually
really curious about this one it looks
like a really fun lo little game fun
little game here we go I am in box
everybody it's super fun
let's do challenge okay
all right what about this challenge
the [ __ ] is this oh my god that music is
incredible
[ __ ] okay this is a lot harder than I
thought
every time I say okay my okay Google
thing disappeared so [ __ ] annoying I
did it it wasn't that hard was I not
completed what I do run okay let's take
a hard challenge how about this ski jump
come on fat back there we go get speed
nailed it nailed it challenge not a
problem
[Music]
really this is fun what about this one
maybe this one
Decker speed come on give me that ten
points oh no I got tread
and point and point the go home and
fight or go home and [ __ ] god damn it
[Music]
yes I am back it would seem I am
completely incapable of playing these
three three games anymore I just can't
seem to enjoy my stuff but this is the
game that I purely enjoy from the bottom
of my heart I've never had more fun and
excitement in a video game
look at that lens flare it looks so real
just like in real life
why would you be in real life when you
can be inside this game right think
about it you could be hoverboarding
forever never run out of battery your
vape will never run deplete of vape
juice and your feeder spinner will never
stop spinning now that's the kind of
life I want to live forever thank you
very much for watching it it's been your
host killer keemstar yes the best game
of all time I am now [ __ ] its rate
next is how I choose to live my life